en de kara bond de 16 avocat au barreau
de paris il est en direct avec nous
bonjour et merci le temps de réagir sur
rt france sans surprise le parlement a
donc définitivement adoptée à cette
proposition de loi sécurité globale
malgré la très forte opposition de la
rue notamment
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire bonjour ma
première réaction que j'ai c'est à
écouter votre journaliste en direct de
l'assemblée nationale il y à 112
parlementaires qui ont pris part au vote
je trouve ça scandaleux nous avons 577
députés en france
s'il n'ya que 112 parlementaire qui
adopte un texte aussi important qui
vient restreindre les libertés
citoyennes les libertés publiques comme
les libertés individuelles sur le fameux
article 24
cet article 24 qui a été réécrit pour
complaire aux médias à vous mais qu'il
protège absolument pas le citoyen alors
que les diffusion d'image abusives avec
une intention malveillante à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre étaient déjà réprimé
par le code pénal alors que le code de
déontologie policière rappelle aux
policiers et aux gendarmes qui n'ont pas
à craindre la diffusion des images par
la population
je trouve que c'est purement scandaleux
le parlement ne remplit plus son rôle
est aujourd'hui il ya un immense débat
sur le reflux des libertés publiques
dans notre pays où on légifère
ordonnancée par décret et comme pour une
fois le parlement est saisi d'une loi il
n'est même pas présent pour en débattre
et pour voter je note d'ailleurs que des
membres de la majorité et je le regrette
comme sacha houcke et pour lequel j'ai
la plus grande estime ailleurs ont
préféré s'abstenir plutôt que voter
contre pourquoi on est en train de vous
poser une question est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre le recul des libertés
publiques ou de sécurité qui est déjà
accordé au code pénal
ce sont donc deux cents également
pourquoi est ce que les membres de la
république en marche n'ont pas voté
pourquoi est ce que la droite
parlementaire n'a pas voté pourquoi est
ce qu'il ya un tel silence en même temps
que le parlement vient se plaindre que
l'article 34 de la constitution n'est
plus respectée par le gouvernement
actuel
c'est très étonnant les îles toi que
vous pourquoi cette si faible
mobilisation
de la part des députés alors c'est
d'abord c'est d'abord aux députés vous
répondra moi je ne vais pas aujourd'hui
venir vous à prendre leur place
convenir leur donner leurs raisons c'est
à eux de s'expliquer et qu'ils auront à
s'expliquer le moment venu devant leurs
électeurs pour dire pourquoi ils ne
remplissent pas leur office de
législateurs c'est à eux de vous
l'expliquer moi je pense que pour les
députés de la reine ils n'ont pas voulu
s'inscrire rencontre puisque le texte
était soutenu par un gérald darmanin qui
est l'actuel ministre de l'intérieur
je pense que la droite n'a pas été très
courageuse et je pense que de toute
façon ils auraient au moins mérité à
s'exprimer sur ce texte sur lequel il y
a de grands espoirs de censure qui sont
fondées par les destins de liberté qui
attendent impatiemment que le conseil
constitutionnel statue parce que
l'article 24 et stylisé toutes les
positions
mais vous avez aussi un immense sujet
sur l'emploi des drones sur le respect
du droit à la vie privée
l'article 9 du code civil le consacre
vous avez en hauteur comme ma consoeur
nathalie dubois qui a longuement
expliqué en quoi ce texte pouvait être
liberticide
vous avez des auteurs majeurs qui ont
pris position ce n'est pas débattue
vous avez un troisième sujet c'est cet
immense mystification du continuum de
sécurité alors que les français payent
des impôts pour être protégés qu'ils ont
le sentiment de ne pas l'être on va leur
demander de payer toujours autant
d'impôts en étant moins protégé puisque
ça sera par des milices privées
écoutez on marche sur la tête et le
législateur refuse de prendre position
en adoptant une discipline partisane ou
pire c'est le choix de la lâcheté pour
ne pas se voir reprocher plus tard de ne
pas avoir voté un texte qui a été
tellement réécrit qu'on ne le comprend
plus ce qui accroît la critique qu'on
peut exprimer à son égard c'est à dire
qui va être source d'insécurité
juridique alors les opposants au texte
notamment la coordination en stop loi
sécuritaire globale à l'origine de
nombreuses manifestations les opposants
annoncent qu'ils ont déposé des
contributions volontaires au conseil
constitutionnel qu'est ce que ça peut
changer quel va être le rôle
du conseil constitutionnel c'est le
dernier recours avant la promulgation du
texte déjà oui comme bien souvent
d'ailleurs en matière de libertés
publiques et individuelles en france
toutes les digues cèdent sauf le conseil
constitutionnel c'est à dire qu'on est
obligé d'attendre qui est neuf sages qui
statue parce que avant les
parlementaires par exemple n'ont pas
joué leur rôle pour prévenir ces
atteintes aux libertés
en quoi va consister le travail du
conseil constitutionnel il va être saisi
sur un certain nombre d'articles dont
par exemple l'article 24 et il va
vérifier si c'est conforme à la
constitution
au bloc de constitutionnalité
c'est-à-dire tout préambule de la
constitution et au principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la république
il y aura à statuer notamment par
exemple sur la liberté de manifester sur
le respect de la vie privée sur la
possibilité et le droit d'informer sur
les réseaux sociaux
quand il ya des débordements possibilité
d'informer qui protège aussi les forces
de l'ordre quand elles mêmes sont
victimes de débordements voilà les
différents points sur lesquels le
conseil constitutionnel devra dire si ce
texte en l'état actuel où il a été voté
au sénat puis à l'assemblée nationale
est conforme ou non aux principes
fondamentaux qui régissent les normes
que nous adoptons et que nous appliquons
en france il faut s'attendre selon voit
de nouveaux rassemblements ces
prochaines semaines contre 7
cette loi sécurité globale écoutez
maintenant qu'elle a été votée je ne
sais pas quelle serait l'utilité de ces
rassemblements sinon de manifester un
mécontentement mais ça de même que pour
connaître les motivations des
parlementaires c'est heureux que je vous
invite à vous tourner de même pour les
manifestations ont interrogé les
organisateurs habituels
je suis désolé n'étant ni parlementaire
ni organisateur de manifestation je suis
pas votre bon interlocuteur
l'occasion de faire réagir ses opposants
au texte merci beaucoup car monde 16
avocat au barreau de paris